Aaron Carter appears to be enjoying the
single life just days after his breakup
with ex Madison Parker absolutely I'm
gonna keep it 100% real I don't care
what you put people back here's the 29
year old singer getting ready for a
casual night out with porcelain black
based on Aaron's tweets the pair stepped
out to grab dinner at Nobu restaurant
before heading to Hollywood hot spa
Dalila with a group of friends while
Aaron says porcelain is one of his
closest friends and they've known each
other for 17 years this pic of the pair
getting cozy sparked romance rumors
that's Aaron planting a kiss on the 31
year old stars cheek captioned a 1 since
day one earlier this month a source told
ET the former child star and Madison had
a very amicable split and I did okay but
when et spoke to the former couple back
in July they seemed ready for a future
together where do you see your life with
Aaron and finish no yeah we're about the
baby
my daughter's P my daughter I know et
has reached out to Aaron's camp for
comment on his new rumored fling
[Music]